I'd like to like to talk about farms day
and optimistic concurrency control which
is the main interesting technique that
uses the reason we're talking about farm
it's this the last paper in the series
about transactions and replication and
sharding and this is still an open
research area where people are totally
not satisfied with performance or in the
kind of performance versus consistency
trade-offs that are available and
they're still trying to do better
and in particular this particular paper
is motivated by the huge performance
potential of these new RDMA NICs
so you may be wondering since we just
read about spanner
how farm differs some spanner both of
them after all replicate and they use
two-phase commit for transactions of
that level they seem pretty similar
spanner as a is a deployed systems been
used a lot for a long time its main
focus is on Geographic replication that
is to be able to have copies on there
like east and west coasts and different
data centers and be able to have
reasonably efficient transactions that
involve pieces of data in lots of
different places and the most innovative
thing about it because in order to try
to solve the problem of how long it
takes to do two-phase commit over long
distances is that it has a special
optimization path for read-only
transactions using synchronized time and
the performance you get out of spanner
if you remember is that a read/write
transaction takes 10 to 100 milliseconds
depending on how close together the
different data centers are farm makes a
very different set of design decisions
and targets a different kind of workload
first of all it's a research prototype
so it's not by any means a finished
product and the goal is to explore the
potential of these new RDMA high speed
networking hardware so it's really still
an exploratory system it assumes that
all replicas are in the same data center
absolutely it doesn't wouldn't make
sense
the replicas were in even in different
data centers let alone on East Coast
versus West Coast so it's not trying to
solve a problem that spanner is about
what happens if an entire data center
goes down can I so get out my data
really that's does the extent that it
has fault tolerance is for individual
crashes or maybe try to recover after a
whole data center loses power and gets
restored again it uses this RDMA
technique which I'll talk about but
already may turns out to seriously
restrict the design options and because
of this farm is forced to use optimistic
concurrency control on the other hand
the performance they get is far far
higher than spanner farm can do a
transit a simple transaction in 58
microseconds and this is from figure 7
and section 6.3 so this is 58
microseconds versus to 10 milliseconds
that the spanner takes is that's about a
hundred times faster than spanner so
that's maybe the main huge differences
that farm us how much higher performance
but is not aimed at Geographic
replication so this you know farms
performance is extremely impressive like
how much faster than anything else
another way to look at it is that
spanner and farm target different
bottlenecks and span are the main
bottleneck the people worried about is
the speed of light and network speed of
light delays and network leaves between
data centers whereas in farm the main
bottlenecks that the design is worried
about is is CPU time on the server's
because they kind of wished away the
speed of light and network delays by
putting all the replicas in the same
data center all right
so sort of the background of how this
fits into the 684 sequence the setup and
farm is that you have it's all running
in one datacenter there's a sort of
configuration manager this which we've
seen before and the configuration
managers in charge of deciding which rep
which
servers should be the primary in the
backup before each shard of data and if
you read carefully you'll see that they
use zookeeper in order to help them
implement this configuration manager but
it's not not the focus of the paper at
all
instead the interesting thing is that
the data is sharded split up by key
across a bunch of primary backup payers
so I mean one shard goes on you know
primary one server primary one backup
one another short one primary to backup
two and so forth and that means that
anytime you update data you need to
update it both on the primary and on the
backup and these are not these primaries
these replicas are not maintained by
PACs or anything like it instead all the
replicas of the data are updated
whenever there's a change and if you
read you always have to read from the
primary the reason for this replication
of course is fault tolerance and the
kind of fault tolerance they get is that
as long as one replicas of a given shard
is available then that shard will be
available so they only require one
living replica not a majority and the
system as a whole if there's say a data
center white power failure it can
recover as long as there's at least one
replicas of every shard in the system
another way of putting that is if you
they have F plus one replicas then they
can tolerate up to F failures for that
shard in addition to the primary backup
copies of each sort of data there's
transaction code that runs it's maybe
most convenient to think of the
transaction code is running as separate
clients in fact they run the transaction
code in their experiments on the same
machines as the actual farm storage
servers but I'll mostly think of them as
as being a separate set of clients and
the clients are running transactions and
the transactions need to read and write
data objects that are stored in the
in the sharded servers in addition these
transaction these clients each client
not only runs the transactions but also
acts as that transaction coordinator for
two-phase commit
okay so it's the basic set up the way
they get performance because this really
this is a paper all about how you can
get high performance and still have
transactions one way they get high
performances with sharding these are the
ingredients in a sense the main way is
through sharding in experiments they
shard their data over 90 ways for 90
servers or maybe it's 45 ways and not
just if as long as the operations and
different shards are more or less
independent of each other that just gets
you an automatic 90 times speed up
because you can run whatever it is
you're running in parallel on 90 syrups
this huge went from shorter sharding um
another trick they play in order to get
good performance as the data all has to
fit in the RAM of the servers they don't
really store the data on disk
it all has to fit in RAM and that means
of course you can get out of pretty
quickly another way that they get high
performance is they need to tolerate
power failures which means that they
can't just be using RAM because they
need to recover the data after a power
failure and RAM loses contents on a
power failure so they have a clever
non-volatile Ram scheme for having the
contents of RAM the data survived power
failures this is in contrast to storing
the data persistently on disk i'm is
much faster than disk um another trick
they play is they use this RDMA
technique which essentially clever
network interface cards that allow that
accept packets that instruct that then
that we're interface card to directly
read and write the memory of the server
without interrupting the server I know
that trick they play is what you often
call kernel bypass
which means that the application level
code can directly access the network
interface card without getting the
kernel involved okay so these are all
the sort of clever tricks we're looking
at out pour it that they used to get
high performance and I'll talk about
we've already talked about sharding a
lot but I'll talk about the rest in this
lecture
okay so first I'll talk about
non-volatile Ram I mean this is really a
topic that doesn't doesn't really affect
the rest of the design directly as I
said all the data and for farm is stored
in RAM when you update it when a client
transaction updates a piece of data what
that really means is it reaches out to
the relevant servers that store the data
and causes those servers to modify the
whatever object is the transaction is
modifying to object modify it right in
RAM and that's as far as the writes get
they don't go to disk and this is you
know contrast to your raft
implementations for example which spent
a lot of time persisting data to disk
there's no persisting and in farm this
is a big wind writing stuff in RAM write
a write to ram takes about 200
nanoseconds whereas a raid even to a
solid state drive which is pretty fast a
right to a stall seek drive takes about
a hundred microseconds and a write to
our hard drive takes about ten
milliseconds so being able to write to
ram is worth many many orders of
magnitude and speed for transactions
that modify things but of course iran
loses its content and a power failure so
it's not persistent by itself as a side
you might think that writing
modifications to the RAM of multiple
servers that if you have replica servers
and you update all the replicas that
that might be persistent enough and so
after all if you have F 1 F +1 replicas
you can tolerate up to F failures and
the reason why just simply writing to
Ram on multiple servers is not good
enough is that a site-wide power failure
will destroy
all of your servers and thus violating
the assumption that the failures are in
different servers are independent so we
need a scheme that it's gonna work even
if power fails to the entire data center
so what what forum does is it it puts a
battery a big battery in every rack and
runs the power supply system through the
batteries so the batteries automatically
take over if there's a power failure and
keep all their machines running at least
until the battery fails but of course
you know the battery is not very big it
may only be able to run their their
machines for say 10 minutes or something
so the battery by itself is not enough
to make this the system be able to
withstand a lengthy power failure so
instead the battery system when it sees
that the main power is failed the
battery system while it keeps the
server's Marling also alerts the
server's all the servers and with some
kind of interrupt or message telling
them look the powers just failed you
know you only got 10 minutes left before
the batteries fail also so at that point
the software on farms servers copies all
of rain active stops all processing it
for farm first and then copies each
server copies all of its RAM to a
solid-state drive attached to that
server I'm what wished could take a
couple minutes and once all the RAM is
copied to the solid-state drive then the
machine shuts itself down and turns
itself off so if all goes well there's a
site-wide power failure all the machines
save their RAM to disk when the power
comes back up in the datacenter all the
machines will when they reboot will read
the memory image that was saved on disk
restored into RAM and but there's some
recovery that has to go on but basically
they won't have lost any of their
persistent state due to the power
failure and so what that really means is
that the farm is using conventional Ram
but it's essentially made the RAM
non-volatile being able to survive power
failures with the
this trick of using a battery having a
battery alert the server having the
server store the RAM content solid-state
drives any questions about the nvram
scheme alright this is a is a useful
trick but it is worthwhile keeping mind
that it really only helps if there's
power failures that is if the you know
the whole sequence of events only it
gets set in train when the battery
notices that the main power is failed if
there's some other reason
causing the server to fail like
something goes wrong with the hardware
or there's a bug in the software that
causes a crash those crashes the
non-volatile Ram system is just nothing
to do with those crashes those crashes
will cause the machine to reboot and
lose the contents of its RAM and it
won't be able to recover them so this
NVRAM scheme is good for power failures
but not other crashes and so that's why
in addition to the NVRAM farm also has
multiple copies multiple replicas of
each shard all right so this NVRAM
scheme essentially eliminates
persistence rates as a bottleneck in the
performance of the system leaving only
as performance bottlenecks the network
and the CPU which is what we'll talk
about next ok so there's a question if
the datacenter power fails and farm lose
everything for solid-state drive would
it be possible to carry all the data to
a different data center and continue
operation there in principle absolutely
in practice I think would be would all
certainly be easier to restore power to
the data center then to move the drives
the problem is there's no power and the
power in the dated old data center so
you'd have to physically move the drives
and the computers maybe just the drives
to the new data center so this was if
you wanted to do this it might be
possible but it's certainly not
it's not what the farm designers had in
mind they assumed the power be restored
okay so that's NVRAM and at this point
we can just ignore nvram for the rest of
the design it doesn't it doesn't really
interact with the rest of the design
except that we know we're have to worry
about writing data to disk all right so
as I mentioned the remaining bottlenecks
once you eliminate having a great data
to disk for persistence in remaining
bottlenecks have to do with the CPU and
the network in fact in farman and indeed
a lot of the systems that i've been
involved with the a huge bottleneck has
been the cpu time required to deal with
network interactions so now we're can
CPU are kind of joint bottlenecks here
farm doesn't have any kind of speed of
light network problems it just has the
problems or it just spends a lot of time
eliminating bottlenecks having to do is
getting network data into and out of the
computers so first as a background I
want to lay out what the conventional
architecture is for getting things like
remote procedure call packets between
applications and on different computers
just so that can we have an idea of why
this approach that farm takes is more
efficient so typically what's going on
is on one computer that maybe wants to
send a procedure call message you might
have an application and then the
application is running in user space
there's a user kernel boundary here the
application makes system calls into the
kernel which are not particularly cheap
in order to send data and then there's a
whole stack of software inside the
kernel involved is sending data over the
network there might be what's usually
called a socket layer that does
buffering which involves copying the
data which takes time there's typically
a complex TCP
the protocol stack that knows all about
things like retransmitting and sequence
numbers and check sums and flow control
there's quite a bit of processing there
at the bottom there's a piece of
hardware called the network interface
card which is has a bunch of registers
that the kernel can talk to to configure
it and it has hardware required to send
bits out over the cable onto the network
and so there's some sort of network
interface card driver in the kernel and
then all self respecting that we're
gonna price cards use direct memory
access to move packets into and out of
host memory so there's going to be
things like queues of packets that the
network interfaces card has D made into
memory the waiting for the kernel to
read and outgoing hues the packets that
the kernel would like then that we're
going to face to car to send as soon as
convenient all right so you want to send
a message like an RPC request let's go
down from the application through the
stack network interface card sends the
bits out on a cable and then there's the
reverse stack on the other side isn't
network interface Hardware here in the
kernel then organ or face might
interrupt the kernel kernel runs driver
Code which hands packets to the TCP
protocol which writes them into buffers
waiting for the application to read them
at some point the application gets
around reading them makes system calls
into the kernel copies the data out of
these buffers into user space this is a
lot of software it's a lot of processing
and a lot of fairly expensive CPU
operations like system calls and
interrupts and copying data as a result
so classical Network communication is
relatively slow it's quite hard to build
an RPC system with the kind of
traditional architecture that can
deliver more than say a few hundred
thousand or BC messages per second and
that might seem like a lot but it's
orders of magnitude too few for the kind
of performance that farm is trying to
target and in general that
couple hundred thousand our pcs per
second is far far less than the speed
that the actual network hardware like
Network wire in the network interface
card is capable of typically these
cables run at things like 10 gigabits
per second it's very very hard to write
our PC software that can generate small
messages of the kind that databases
often need to use it's very hard to
write software in this style that can
generate or absorb anything like 10
gigabits per second of messages that's
millions maybe tens of millions of
messages per second ok so this is the
plan that farm doesn't use and a sort of
a reaction to to this plan instead farm
uses - - ideas to reduce the costs of
pushing packets around the first one
I'll call kernel bypass and the idea
here is that instead of the application
sending all its data down through a
complex stack of kernel code instead the
application the kernel configures the
protection machinery in the computer to
allow the application direct access to
network interface card so the
application can actually reach out and
touch the network interfaces registers
and tell it what to do in addition the
network interface card when it DMAs
and this kernel bypass scheme it DNA's
directly into application memory where
the application can see the bytes
arriving directly without kernel
intervention and when the application
needs to send data the application can
create queues that the network interface
card can directly read with DMA and send
out over the wire so now we've
completely eliminated all the kernel
code involved in networking kernels just
not involved there's no system calls
there's no interrupts
the application just directly reason why
it's memory that the network interface
card sees and of course the same thing
on the other side and this is a this is
an idea that is actually was not
possible years ago with network
interface cards but most modern serious
network interface cards okay can be set
up to do this it does however require
that the application you know you know
all those things that TCP was doing for
you like check sums or retransmission
the application would now be in charge
if we wanted to do this you can actually
do this yourself kernel bypass using a
toolkit that you can find on the way up
called
DP DK and it's relatively easy to use
and allows people to write extremely
high performance networking applications
but and so so form does use this it's
applications directly you talk to the
neck the neck DM ace things right into
application memory we have a student
question I'm sorry yes does this mean
that farm machines run a modified
operating system well I I don't know the
actual answer that question I believe
farm is runs on Windows some form of
Windows whether or not they had to
modify Windows I do not know in the sort
of Linux world in Linux world there's
already full support for this
it does require kernel intervention
because the kernel has to be willing to
give ordinarily application code cannot
do anything directly with devices so
Linux has had to be modified to allow
the allow the kernel to delegate
hardware access to applications so it
does require kernel modifications those
monitor occasions are already in Linux
and maybe already in Windows also in
addition though this
on fairly intelligent Knicks because of
course you're going to have multiple
applications that want to play this game
with a network interface card and so
modern NICs actually know about talking
to multiple distinct cues so that you
can have multiple applications each with
its own set of cues and the the Nick
knows about so it did it has required
modification of a lot of things okay
so sort of step one is is Colonel bypass
idea step two is even cleverer next and
now we're starting to get into hardware
that is not in wide use of the moment
you can buy it commercially but it's not
the default is this RDMA scheme which is
remote direct memory access and here
this is sort of special kind of network
interface cards that support remote
support our DMA so now we have an RDM a
neck both sides have to have these
special network interface cards so I'm
drawing these is connected by a cable in
fact always there's a switch here that
has connections to many different
servers and allows any server to talk to
any server okay so we have these RDMA
necks and we had again we have the
applications and application assist
memory and now though the application
can essentially send a special message
through the neck that asks so we have a
an application on the source host and
maybe we wouldn't call this the
destination host can send a special
message through the our DMA system that
tells this network interface card to
directly read or write a byte some bytes
of memory probably a cache line of
memory in
the target applications address space
directly so hardware and software on the
network interface controller are doing a
read and write read or write of the
application target applications memory
directly and then so we have a sort of
request going here that causes the read
or write and then sending the result
back to really two other incoming queue
on the source application and the cool
thing about this is that this computer's
the CPU this application didn't know
anything about the read or write the
read or write is executed completely in
firmware in the network interface card
so it's not there's no interrupts here
the application didn't have to think
about the request or think about
replying network interface card just
reads or writes a memory and sends a
result back to the source application
and this is much much lower overhead way
of getting at of all you need to do is
read or write memory and stuff in the
RAM of the target application this is a
much faster way of doing a simple read
or write than sending in our PC call
even with magic kernel bypass networking
it's a question does this mean that
already may always require kernel bypass
to work at all you know I don't know the
answer to that I think I've only ever
heard it used in conjunction with kernel
bypass cuz you know the people who are
interested in any of this or are
interested in it only for tremendous
performance and I think you would waste
you throw away a lot of the performance
I'm guessing you throw away a lot of the
performance win if you had to send the
requests through the kernel okay another
question that the the question notes
TCP software's TCP supports in order
delivery duplicate detection and a lot
of other excellent properties which you
actually need and so it would actually
be extremely awkward if this setup
sacrificed reliable delivery or in order
delivery and so the answer the question
is actually these are DMA NICs run their
own reliable sequenced protocol that's
like TCP although not TCP between the
necks and so when you ask your already
am a neck to do a read or write it'll
keep you transmitting until if the you
know if the request is lost and keep
reassurance meaning till it gets a
response and it actually tells the
originating software did the request
succeed or not so you get an
acknowledgment back finally so yeah you
know in fact have to sacrifice
most of TCP is good properties now this
stuff only works over a local network I
don't believe our DMA would be
satisfactory like between distant data
centers so there's all tuned up for very
low speed of light access okay a
particular piece of jargon that the
paper uses is one-sided our DMA and
that's basically what I've just
mentioned when application uses our DMA
to read or write the memory of another
that's one site our DMA now in fact farm
uses our DMA to send messages in an RPC
like protocol so in fact sometimes farm
directly reads with one sided our DMA
but sometimes what farm is using our DMA
for is to append a message to an
incoming message queue inside the target
so sometimes what the what the
well actually always with writes what
farm is actually doing is using our DMA
to write to append a new message to an
incoming queue in the target which the
target will pull since there's nobody
interrupts here the way target
the way the destination of a message
like this knows I got the messages that
periodically checks one of these keys
queues and memory to see how have I
gotten a recent message from anyone
okay so once I did already MA is just to
read or write but using our DMA to send
a message or append either to a message
queue or to a log
sometimes farm appends messages or log
entries to a log and another server also
uses our DMA and you know this memory
that's being written into is all
non-volatile so all of it the message
queues it's all written to disk if
there's a power failure the performance
of this is the figure 2 shows that you
can get 10 million small our DMA reads
and writes per second which is fantastic
far far faster than you can send
messages like our pcs using TCP and the
latency of using our DMA to do a simple
read or write is about 5 microseconds so
again this is you know very very short 5
microseconds is it's slower than
accessing your own local memory but it's
faster than sort of anything else people
do in networks ok so this is sort of a
promise there's this fabulous our DMA
technology that came out a while ago
that at the farm people wanted to
exploit you know the coolest possible
thing that you could imagine doing with
this is using our DMA one sign it
already am a reason rights to directly
do all the reason writes a records
stored in database servers memory so
wouldn't be fantastic if we could just
never talk to the database server CPU or
software but just get at the data that
we need you know in five microseconds a
pop using direct one-sided our DMA
Reiser writes so in a sense this paper
is about you know you you start there
what do you have to do to actually build
something useful so an interesting
question by the way is could you in fact
implement transactions
using one-sided RDMA that is you know
anything we wanted to read or write data
in server the only use already may and
never actually send messages that have
to be interpreted by the server software
it's worth thinking about
in a sense farm is answering that
question with a no because that's not
really how farm works but but it is
absolutely worth thinking how come
pure one-sided RDMA couldn't be made to
work alright so the challenges to using
our DMA in a transactional system that
has replication and sharding so that
that's the challenge we have is how to
combine already made with transactions
charting and replication because you
need to have sharding and transactions
replication to have a seriously useful
database system it turns out that all
the protocols we've seen so far for
doing transactions replication require
active participation by the server
software that is the server has to be in
all the protocols we've seen so far the
server's actively involved in helping
the clients get at read or write the
data so for example in the two-phase
commit schemes we've seen the server has
to do things like decide whether a
record is locked and if it's not walk
set the lock on it right it's not clear
how you could do that with our DMA the
server has to do things like in spanner
you know there's all these versions it
was the server that was thinking about
how to find the latest version similarly
if we have transactions in two-phase
commit
data on the server it's not just data
there's committed data there's data
that's been written but hasn't committed
yet and again traditionally it's the
server that sorts out whether data
recently updated data is committed yet
and that's to sort of protect the
clients from you know prevent them from
seeing data that's locked or not yet
known to be committed and what that
means is that without some clever
thought
RDMA or one-sided pure use of our DME
one-sided RDMA doesn't seem to be
immediately compatible with transactions
and replication and indeed farm while
farm does use one-sided it reads to get
out directly at data in the database it
is not not able to use one-sided rights
to modify the data okay so this leads us
to optimistic concurrency control it
turns out that the main trick in a sense
that farm uses to allow it both use RDMA
and get transactions is by using
optimistic concurrency control so if you
remember I mentioned earlier that
concurrency control schemes are kind of
divided into two broad categories
pessimistic and optimistic pessimistic
schemes use locks and the idea is that
if you have a transaction that's gonna
read or write some data before you can
read or write the data or look at it at
all it must acquire a lock and it must
wait for the lock and so you read about
two-phase locking for example in that
reading from 633 so before you use data
you have to lock it and you hold the
lock for the entire duration of the
transaction and only if the transaction
commits or aborts do you release the
lock and if there's conflicts because
two transactions want to write the same
data at the same time or one wants to
read and one that monster right they
can't do it at the same time one of them
has to block or all but one of the
transactions that went to you some data
missed a block wait for the lock to be
released um and of course this locking
scheme is the fact that the data has to
be locked and that somebody has to keep
track of who owns the lock and when the
lock is released etcetera
this is one thing that makes our DMA
it's not clear how you can do rights or
even reads using our DMA in a locking
scheme because somebody has to enforce
the locks I'm being a little tentative
about this because I suspect that with
more clever our DMA NICs that could
support a wider range of operations like
atomic test and set
you might someday be able to do a
locking scheme with pure one-sided RDMA
but farm doesn't do it okay so what farm
actually uses as an optimistic scheme
and here in an optimistic scheme you can
use at least you can read without
locking you just read the data you don't
know yet whether you are allowed to read
the data or whether somebody else is in
the model middle of modifying it or
anything you just read the data and a
transaction it uses what it whatever it
happens to be and you also don't
directly write the data in optimistic
schemes instead you buffered so you
buffer writes locally and in the client
until the transaction finally ends and
then when the transaction finally
finishes and you want to try to commit
it there's a validate what's called a
validation stage in which the
transaction processing system tries to
figure out whether the actual reason
rights you did were consistent with
serializability that is they try to
figure out oh was somebody writing the
data while I was reading it and if they
were boy
we can't commit this transaction because
it computed with garbage instead of
consistent read values and so if the
validation succeeds then you commit and
if the validation doesn't succeed if you
detect somebody else was messing with
the data while you were trying to use it
at abort so that means that if there's
conflicts if you're reading or writing
data and some other transactions also
modifying at the same time
optimistic schemes abort at that point
because the computation is already
incorrect at the commit point that is
you already read the damage data you
weren't supposed to read so there's no
way to for example block you know until
things are okay
instead the transactions already kind of
poisoned and just has to abort and
possibly be try okay so farm uses
optimistic because he wants to be able
to use one-sided RDMA to just read
whatever's there very quickly so this
this design was really forced by use of
our DMA this is often abbreviated OCC
for optimistic concurrency control all
right and then the interesting thing an
optimistic concurrency control protocols
is how validation works how do you
actually detect that somebody else was
writing the data while you were trying
to use it and that's actually mainly
gonna be what I talked about in the rest
of this lecture and just again though
just to retire this back to the top
level of the design what this is doing
for farm is that the reads can use
one-sided RDMA because and therefore be
extremely fast because we're gonna check
later whether the reads were okay all
right farms a research prototype it
doesn't support things like sequel it
supports a fairly simple API for
transactions this is the API just to
give you a tease for what a transaction
code might actually look like if you
have a transaction it's gotta to clear
the start of the transaction because we
need to say oh this particular set of
Reason rights needs to occur as a
complete transaction the code declares a
new transaction by calling TX create
this is all laid out by the way in the
paper I think from 2014 a slightly
earlier paper by the same authors
you create a new transaction and then
you explicitly read those functions to
read objects and you have to supply an
object identifier an OID indicating what
object you want to read then you get
back some object and you can modify the
object in local memory and we didn't
write it you have a copy of it that
you've read from the server the TX read
back from the server so you know you
might increment some field in the object
and then when you want to update an
object you call this TX right and again
you give it the object ID and the new
object contents and finally when you're
through with all of this you've got to
tell the assistant to commit this
transaction actually do validation and
if it succeeds cause the rights to
really take effect and be visible and
you call this commit routine the
community team runs a whole bunch of
stuff in figure 4 which we'll talk about
and it returns this okay value and it's
required to tell the application oh did
the commit succeed or was it aborted so
we need the return this okay return
valued you know correctly indicate by
the transaction succeeded okay there's
some questions one is question since OCC
aborts if there's contention question is
whether retries involve exponential
back-off because otherwise it seems like
if you just instantly be tried and that
there were a lot of transactions all
trying to update the same value at the
same time they'd all aboard they'd all
retry and waste a lot of time and I
don't know the answer to that question I
don't remember seeing them mentioning
exponential back-off in the paper but it
would make a huge amount of sense to
delay between retries and to increase
the delay to give somebody a chance of
succeeding this is much like the
randomization of the raft collects
Tanner's another question is the farm
API closer in spirit to a no sequel
database yeah you know that's one way of
viewing it it really that it doesn't
have any of the fancy query stuff like
joins for example that sequel has it's
really a very low-level kind of
readwrite interface plus the transaction
support so you you can sort of view it
as a no sequel database maybe with with
transactions all right this is what a
transaction looks like and these are all
these are library calls created
read/write commit commit as a sort of
complex write recall that actually runs
the transaction coordinator code first
what a rare variant of two-phase commit
this described in figure four just
repeat that the while the recall goes
off and actually reads the relevant
server the right call just locally
buffers then the new the modified object
and it's only in commit that the objects
are sent to the servers these object IDs
are actually compound identifiers for
objects and they contain two parts one
is the identify a region which is that
all the memory of all the servers is
split up into these regions and the
configuration manager sort of tracks
which servers replicate which region
number so there's a reason number in
here and then and then you you know you
client can look up in a table the
current primary and backups for a given
region number and then there's an
address such as the straight memory
address within that region and so the
client uses the reason number to pick
the primary in the backup to talk to and
then it hands the address to the our DMA
NIC and tells it look please read at
this address in order to get fetch this
object
alright another piece of detail we have
to get out of the way is to look at the
server memory layout I'm in any one
server there's a bunch of stuff in
memory so one part is that the server
has in its memory its if it's it's
replicating one or more regions it has
the actual regions and or what a reason
contains is a whole bunch of these
objects and each object there's a lot of
objects objects sitting in memory each
object has in it a header which contains
the version number so these are
versioned objects but each object only
has one version at a time so this is
version number and in the high bit let
me try again here and the high bit of
each version number is a lock flag so in
the header of an object there's a lock
flag and the high bit and then a version
number in a little bit and then the
actual data of the object so each object
has the same servers memory it's the
same layout a lock bit in the high bit
and the current version number a little
bit and every time the system writes
modifies an object it increases the
version number and let's see how the
lock bits are used in a couple minutes
in addition in the server's memory there
are pairs of cue pairs of message queues
and logs one for every other computer in
the system so that means that you know
if there's four other servers in the
system that are running or if there's
four servers that are running
transactions there's going to be four
logs sitting in memory that can be
appended to with our DMA one for each of
the other servers and that means that
one for each of the other computers can
run transactions so that means that the
transaction code running on you know so
number of them you know it's the
transaction code running on computer to
when it wants to talk to this server and
append to its log which as well see it's
actually going to append to server twos
log in this servers memory so there's a
total N squared of these queues floating
around in in in each servers memory and
it certainly seems like there's actually
one set of logs which are meant to be I
would non-volatile and then also
possibly a separate set of message
queues which are used just for more RPC
like communication again one in each
server one queue message incoming
message cube per other server written
with our DMA writes all right actually
the next thing to talk about is a year
four in the paper
this is feet four and this explains the
occ commit protocol that farm uses and
I'm gonna go through mostly steps one by
one and actually to to begin with I'm
gonna focus only on the concurrency
control part of this it turns out these
steps also do replication as well as
implement serializable transactions but
we'll talk about the replication for
fault tolerance a little bit later okay
so the first thing that happens is the
execute phase and this is the TX reads
and TX writes the reason writes that the
client transaction is doing and so each
of these arrows here what this means is
that the transaction runs on computer C
and when
needs to read something it uses
one-sided RDMA we to simply read it out
of the relevant primary servers memory
so what we got here was a primary backup
primary backup primary backup for three
different shards and we're imagining
that our transaction read something from
one object from each of these shards
using one-sided RDMA reason that means
these blindingly fast five microseconds
each okay so the client reads everything
it needs to read for the transaction
also anything that's going to write it
first reads and it has to do it do this
read has to first read because it needs
to get the version number
the initial version number all right so
that's the execute phase then when the
transaction calls TX commits to indicate
that it's totally done the library on
the you know the TX commit call on on
the client acts as a transaction
coordinator and runs this whole protocol
which is a kind of elaborate version of
two-phase commit the first phase and
that's described in terms of rounds of
messages so the transaction coordinator
sends a bunch of LOC messages and wait
for them to reply and then validate
messages and waste for the all the
replies so the first phase in the commit
protocol is the lock fees in this phase
what the client is sending is it sends
to each primary the identity of the
object in for each object for clients
written and needs to send that updated
object to the relevant primary so it
sends the updated objects the primary
and as an as a new log entry in the
primaries log you know for this client
so the client really abusing already
made to append to the primaries log and
what it's appending is the object ID of
the writ of the object wants to write
the version number that the client
initially read when it read the object
and the new value
so it appends the object of yours number
and new value to the primary logon for
the primary beach of the charge that
it's written an object in so these I
guess what's going on here is that the
this transaction wrote two different
objects one on primary one and the other
on primary to know when this is done
when the transaction coordinator gets
back the well alright so now the these
new log records are sitting in the logs
of the primaries the primary though has
to actually actively process these log
entries because it needs to check and
they sort of do a number of checks
involved with validation to see if the
if this primary is part of the
transaction can be allowed to commit so
at this point we have to wait for each
primary to to poll the this clients log
in the primaries memory see that there's
a new log entry and process that new log
entry and then send a yes-or-no vote to
say whether it is or is not willing to
do its part of the transaction all right
so what does the primary do when it's
polling loop sees that an incoming lock
log entry from a client first of all if
that object with the object ID is
currently blocked then the primary
rejects this lock message and sends back
a message to the client using RDMA
saying no that this transaction cannot
be allowed to proceed I'm voting no and
two-phase commit and that will cause the
transaction coordinator to abort the
transaction and the other is not locked
then the next thing the primary does is
check the version numbers it checks to
make sure that the version number that
the client sent it that is the version
number of the client originally read is
unchanged and if the version numbers
changed that means that between when our
transaction read and when it wrote
somebody else wrote the object if the
version numbers changed and so the
version numbers changed again the
primary will respond no and forbid the
transaction from continuing but if the
version number is the same in the lock
that's not set
and the primary will set the lock and
return a positive response back to the
client now because the primary's
multi-threaded running on multiple CPUs
and there may be other transactions
there may be other CPUs reading other
incoming log cues from other clients at
the same time on the same primary there
may be races between different
transactions or lock the clock record
processing from different transactions
trying to modify the same object so the
primary actually uses an atomic
instruction a compare and swap
instruction in order to both check check
the version number and lock and set the
lock a bit on that version number as an
atomic operation and this is the reason
why the lock of it has to be in the high
bits of the version number so that a
single instruction can do a compare and
swap on the version number and the lock
bit okay now one thing to note is that
if the objects already locked
there's no blocking there's no waiting
for the lock to be released the primary
simply sends back a know if some other
transaction has it locked alright any
questions about the lock fees of of
Committee all right back in the trend
head in the client which is acting his
transaction coordinator it waits for
responses from all the primaries from
the primaries of the shard so for every
object that the transaction modified if
any of them say no if they need them
reject the transaction then the
transaction coordinator aborts the whole
transaction and actually sends out
messages to all the primaries saying I
changed my mind I don't want to commit
this transaction after all but if they
all answered yes of all the primaries
answer yes then the transaction
coordinator thinks that decides that the
transaction can actually commit but the
primaries of course don't know whether
they all voted yes
or not so the transaction coordinator
has to notify every ball the primary so
yes deed everybody voted yes so please
do actually commit this and the way the
client does this is by appending another
record to the logs of the primaries for
each modified object this time it's a
commit backup record that it's a pending
and the this time the transaction
coordinator I'm sorry I did commit
primary I'm skipping over valide didn't
commit backup for now I'll talk about
those later so just ignore those for the
moment the transaction coordinator goes
on to commit primary sends pens that
commit primary to each primaries log and
the transaction coordinator only has to
wait for the hardware RDMA
acknowledgments it doesn't have to wait
for the primary just actually process
the log record the transaction
coordinator it turns out as soon as it
gets a single acknowledgment from any of
the primaries it can return yes the okay
equals true to the transactions
signifying that the transaction six
succeeded and then there's another stage
later on where the once the transaction
coordinator knows that every primary
knows that the transaction coordinated
committed you can tell all the primaries
that they can discard all the log
entries for this transaction okay now
there's one last thing that has to
happen the primaries which are looking
at the logs their polling the Long's
they'll notice that there's a commit
primary record at some point and then on
the primary that receives the commit
primary log entry will it knows that it
had locked that object previously and
that the object must still be locked so
what the primary will do is update the
object in its memory with the new
contents that were previously sent in
the lock message I'm increment the
version number associated with that
object and finally clear the lock bit on
that object and what that means is that
as soon as a primary
receives and processes a commit primary
log message it may since it clears the
lock a bit and updates the data it may
well expose this new data to other
transactions other transactions after
this point are free to use it are free
to use the object with its new value and
new version number all right I'm gonna
do an example any questions about the
machinery before I start thinking about
an example feel free to ask questions
any time alright so how about an example
let's suppose we have two transactions
transaction one and transaction two and
they're both trying to do the same thing
they both just wanna increment X X is
the object sitting off in some servers
memory so so both we got two
transactions running running through
this before we look into what actually
happens we should remind ourselves what
the valid possibilities are for the
outcomes so and that's all about
serializability farm guaranteed
serialize ability so that means that
whatever farm actually does it has to be
equivalent to some one at a time
execution of these two transactions so
we're allowed to see was the results you
would see if t1 ran and then strictly
afterwards t2 ran or we can see the
results that could ensue if t2 ran and
then t1 run those are the only
possibilities now in fact farm is
entitled to abort a transaction so we
also have to consider the possibility
that one of the two transactions aborted
or indeed that they both aborted I since
they're doing both doing the same thing
there's a certain amount of symmetry
here so one possibility is that they
both committed and that means two
increments happen so one legal
possibilities that X is equal to 2 and
both then the TX
it has to agree with whether things a
bit or aborted or committed so that both
transactions need to CTX commit returned
true in this case another possibility is
that only one of them transactions
committed and the other aborted and then
we want to see only one true and the
other false and another possibilities
maybe they both aborted we don't think
this could necessarily happen but it's
actually legal so that X isn't changed
and we want both to get false back from
TX commit so we better better not see
anything other than these three options
all right so of course what happens
depends on the timing so I'm going to
integrate out various different ways
that the commit protocol could in early
even for convenience I have a handy
reminder of what the actual commit
protocol is here so one possibility is
that they run exactly in lockstep they
both send all their messages at the same
time they both read at the same time I'm
going to assume that X starts out as
zero if they both read at the same time
that we're going to see zero I assume
they both sent out lakh messages at the
same time
and indeed they accompany their log
messages with the value one since
they're adding 1 to it and that if they
commit if they walk messages say yes
then they would if they did both commit
at the same time so if if this is the
scenario what's going to happen and why
you
they like to raise their hand and hazard
a guess
well that's really good field to be
since that's a one-sided read can't
possibly fail they're both gonna send in
fact identical walk messages to whatever
primary holds object X and I both send
the same version number but a version
number they read and the same value so
the primaries gonna see to log meant to
log messages in two different incoming
logs assuming these are running on
different clients and exactly what
happens now is slightly left up to our
imagination by the paper but I think the
two incoming log messages could be
processed in parallel on different cores
on the primary but the critical
instruction of the primary is the atomic
test and set or compare and swap exactly
somebody's volunteer the answer that one
of them will get to the compare and swap
instruction first and whichever core I
guess the compare and swap instruction
first it'll set the lock bit on that
objects version and will observe the
lock a bit wasn't previously set which
everyone executes the atomic
compare-and-swap second will observe the
lock that's already set I mean he's the
one of the two will return yes and the
other two will fail the lock observe the
lock is already set immature no and you
know it for symmetry I'm just going to
imagine that transaction to the primary
sends back a no so the transaction to
use client code will abort transaction 1
I've got the lock got a yes back and it
will actually commit when it come
it's when the primary actually gets the
commit message it'll install the updated
object
you know increments to to clear the lock
bit increment the version and return
true this is gonna say true because the
other primary sent back I know that
means that TX commits gonna return false
here and the final value would be x
equals one that was one of our allowed
outcomes but of course it's not the only
in are leaving any questions about how
this played out or wide executed the way
it did
okay so there's other possible
interleavings so how about how about
this one let's imagine that transaction
2 does the beat first
she doesn't really matter what the reads
are concurrent or not then transaction
one doesn't read and then transaction
went a little bit faster and it gets its
lock message in and a reply and gets a
commit back and then afterwards
transaction two gets going again and
sends a lock message in if it could
commit so what happens this time
well is this law commissioner is gonna
be succeed because there's no reason to
believe there's a lock bit is set
because the second lock message hasn't
even been sent message we'll set the
lock the commit message this commit
primary message should actually clear
the lock a bit so the lock bit will be
clear by the time t2 census inserts its
lock entry in primaries log so this the
primary won't see the lock a bit set at
this point yeah so somebody's
volunteered that what this primary will
see is that the version number so the
the lock message contains the version
number the transaction to originally
read and so the primary is gonna see
wait a minute this since commit primary
increments of version number the the
primary is gonna see that the version
number is wrong there's numbers now
higher on the real object and so it's
actually gonna send back a a no response
to the coordinator and the coordinator
is gonna abort this transaction and
again we're gonna get x equals 1 one of
the transactions return true the other
returned false which is the same final
outcome as before and it is allowed any
questions about how this played out a
slightly different scenario would be as
if and actually okay the slightly
different scenario I was gonna think of
think of was one in which the commit
message was stole it happened after this
lock this is essentially the same as the
first scenario in which this transaction
got the lock set in this transaction
observed lock okay
everyone one last scenario let's suppose
we see this
what's going to happen this time
[Music]
yeah somebody has a right answer at the
of course the first transaction will go
through because there's no contention in
the first transaction the second
transaction when it goes to read X will
actually see the new version number as
incremented by the commit primary
processing on the primary so it'll see
the new version number the lock that
won't be set and so then when it goes to
send its lock log entry to the primary
lock lock that locked processing code in
the primary Co the locks not set and the
version is the same hasn't this is the
latest version and it all I want to
commit and so for this the outcome we're
gonna see is x equals 2 because this
read not only read the new version um
but actually read the new value which
was one so this is incorrect here and
both calls to TX commit will be true yes
that's right succeed it with x equals 2
all right so you know this happened to
work out in these cases the intuition
behind why optimistic concurrency
control provides serializability why it
why it basically checks that the
execution that did happen is the same as
a one at a time execution essentially
the intuition is that if there was no
conflicting transaction then the version
numbers and the lock bits won't have
changed if nobody else is messing with
these objects you know I'll see the same
version numbers at the end of the
transaction as we did when we first read
the object whereas if there is a
conflicting transaction between when we
read the object and when we try to
commit a change and that conflicting
modified something then if it actually
started to commit we will see a new
version number or a lock a bit set so
the comparison of the version numbers
and lock bits between when you first
read the object and when you finally
commit it kind of tells you whether some
other commits to the objects snuck in
while you were using them all right and
you know the cool thing to remember here
is that this allowed us to do the reads
the use of this optimistic schema which
we don't actually check the locks only
when we first use the data allowed us to
use this extremely fast one sided
already ma reads to read the data and
get high performance ok so the way I've
explained it so far without validate and
without commit back up is the way the
system works but as I see validate is
sort of an optimization for just reading
an object but not writing it and commit
back up as part of the scheme for fault
tolerance I think I'm gonna a few
minutes we have left I want to talk
about validate so the validate stage is
it's an optimization for to treat
objects that we're only read by the
transaction and I'm not written and it's
going to be particularly interesting if
it's a straight read-only transaction
that modified nothing and you know the
optimization is that it's going to be
that the transaction coordinator can
execute the validate with a one-sided
read that's extremely fast rather than
having to put something on a log and
wait for the primary to see our log
entry and think about it so this
validates one-sided B is going to be
much much faster it's gonna essentially
replace lock for objects that would only
read it's gonna be much faster
basically what's going on here is that
the what what the validate does is the
transaction coordinator refetch is the
object header so you know it would have
read an object say this object in the
execute phase when it's committing it
instead of sending a lock message it be
fetches the object hit header and checks
whether the version number now is the
same as the version number when it first
read the object and it also checks if
the lock of it is clear so so that's how
it works
so instead of setting a lock message
send this validate message should be
much faster for a read-only operation so
let me put up another transaction
example and run through it how it works
let's suppose x and y are initially 0 we
have two transactions t1 if X is equal
to zero set y equal one and T two says
if Y is zero
said x equals one but this is a
absolutely classic test for strong
consistency if the execution is
serializable it's going to be either t1
then t2 or t2 and t1 it's got to get to
see any you know corrected
implementation has to get the same
results it's running them one at a time
if you run T 1 and then t2 you're gonna
get y equals 1 and x equals 0 because
the second if statement Y is already 1
the second if statement won't do
anything and symmetrically this will
give you x equals 1 and y equals 0 and
it turns out that if you if they both
abort you can get x equals 0 y equals 0
but what you are absolutely not allowed
to get is x equals 1 y equals 1 that's
not allowed
ok so we're looking for how I'm going to
use this as a test see what happens with
validate and again we're gonna suppose
these two transactions execute most so
obvious cases they execute it absolutely
at the same time and it eat that's the
that's the hardest case okay so as we
have read of X meet Y
why because we wrote it and lock why
here I sort of lock X here but since now
we're using this read-only a validation
optimization that means this one has to
validate why this one has to validate X
you know it's a red X but didn't write
it so it's going to validate it much
quicker and maybe it's going to commit
and maybe it's and so the question is if
we use this validate as I described it
that just checks the version number and
lock but haven't the version number
hasn't changed in the lock but isn't set
will we get a a correct answer
and no actually both the validation is
gonna fail for both because when these
LOC messages were processed by the
relevant primaries they cause the LOC a
bit just to be set initially presumably
the the reason okay did a cleared lock
bin but when we come to validate even
though the client is doing the one-sided
read of the object header for X&Y it's
gonna see the lock bit that was set by
the processing of these lock requests
and so they're both gonna see the lock
bits set on the object that they merely
read and they're both going to abort and
neither X nor Y will be modified and so
that was one of the legal outcomes
that's right somebody somebody notice
this indeed both validates will fail
another of course sometimes that a
transaction can go through and here's a
scenario in which it does work out
this was transaction one is a little
faster validates
all right so what's going to happen a
transaction one is a little bit faster
so this time it's validates gonna
succeed because nothing has happened to
X between when transaction 1 read it and
when it validated so presumably the lock
also went through without any trouble
because nobody's modified Y here either
so the primary answered yes for this the
one-sided read revealed an unchanged
version number and lock bit here and so
transaction one can commit and it will
have incremented Y but by this point if
this is the order when the primary
process is this actually when the
primary process is lock of X this will
also go through with no problem because
nobody's modified X when the primary for
Y processes the validate for Y though
it's I'm sorry when the client running
transaction two refetch is the version
number unlocked it for y it's either
gonna see this really depends on whether
the committee's happen if the commit
hasn't happened yet this valid a will
see that the lock bit is set because it
was set back here if the commit has
happened already then the lock bit of
will be clear but this validate
one-sided reader will see a different
version number than was originally seen
and it needs somebody it's just this
answer so one will commit so that
transaction one will commit and
transaction to will abort
and although I don't have time to talk
about it here if there's a straight
read-only transaction then there doesn't
need to be a locking phase and there
doesn't need to be a commit phase pure
read-only transactions can be done with
just just reading blind reads for the
reads
sorry one-sided RDMA reads for the reads
one-sided already me reads for the
validates and so they're extremely fast
read-only transactions are and don't
require any work any attention by the
server
so and this is at the heart you know
trends these reads and indeed though
everything about farm is very
streamlined - partially due to our DMA
and it uses OCC because it's basically
forced to in order to be able to do
reads without checking locks there are a
few brown downsides though it turns out
optimistic concurrency control really
works best if there's relatively few
conflicts if there's conflicts all the
time then transactions will have to
board and there's a you know a bunch of
other restrictions I already mentioned
like on farm like the data must all fit
in the RAM and all the computers must
mean that the same data center
nevertheless this was viewed at the time
and still as just a very surprisingly
high-speed implementation of distributed
transactions like just much faster than
any system in sort of in production use
and it's true that Hardware involves a
little bit exotic and really depends on
this non-volatile Ram scheme and it
depends on these special RDMA NICs and
those are not particularly pervasive now
but you do but you can get them and with
performance like this it seems likely
that they'll both in viewing and already
me will eventually be pretty pervasive
in data centers so that people can play
these kind of games and that's all I
have to say about farm happy to take any
questions if anybody has some and if not
I'll see you next week with a spark
which is you may be happy to know
absolutely not about transactions I
heard everyone bye-bye
[Music]